My personal life is not exactly vulgar
But it is certainly this Mim
I'm okay.
Yeah.
My personal life has recently exploded that is true and it has been difficult.
In fact many people tried to communicate with me
seriously
Are you fine?
Um, your tweets on Twitter recently have ..
It aroused my concern
No,
No, in case you were wondering
Definitely not okay.
But if your life goes off or turns, what can you do?
Frankly, all I was doing was drinking,
Crying ugly and trying to distract myself from this whole mess
Because the only thing that can help me is time.
a lot of time.
So if you find that your life has also collapsed
Here are some things you can do.
First you definitely want to rely on friends and family.
Everyone needs a support group
And I was relying on my group.
Much.
It can be ten o'clock at night, when I feel the beginning of the cold cold feelings of loneliness and despair
Then I start sending written texts to everyone I know.
I am very lucky because I have amazing friends
I can talk to them sometimes at three in the morning
They listen to me and give me advice.
thanks friends!
The next thing you want to do is go to your therapist (psychologist)
If you do not receive treatment, I advise you to start.
Because it / they can give you a lot of valuable advice to help you in the tragedy that is your current life.
It seems like all you're doing to deal with this situation is to drink.
And crying.
And .. that's good .. but I think you should also start incorporating adaptive mechanisms ..
More healthy in the process of your grief
Such as making sure you're getting enough sleep, keeping exercise and having a healthy diet -
I went to three nightclubs this month alone
Well this ..
If I did not listen to music or podcasts in the car, the calm would be quite dark
Immediately burst out crying.
Hahaha
Well this is ...
Yes, I feel that I am broken, as if everything is fueled by fire
As if the house would fall at any moment
Well why do not you take a deep breath for me now?
Deep rudeness
Ha ha ha!
Depending on the extent of your life, you will pass through these stages for some time.
In the end, you'll need to start taking care of yourself and rebuilding your life.
I'm not at that stage yet, I'm still in despair.
But I've definitely started taking steps to get to that stage.
For example, I joined a new pilates department because I need more endorphins now than ever before.
I followed a new hobby of 'bowling' and rock climbing so I could go out with my friends
And adopted a new cat!
Just joking.
But seriously at this stage, who cares how much of a cat I have .. I will die alone.
But if your life is in a state of collapse, encourage you to try to 'embrace' the worst part of it.
For example you can cry in a night club ..
But at least you're in a night club, trying to have a fun time.
You can go out with your friends and end up falling on the stairs
And entering the men's bath and then want to die in the extreme embarrassment.
But at least you are with your friends, trying to have fun.
You can try writing a video script for YouTube and start feeling hopeless
And crying too, but still writing a screenplay for a video in an effort to have fun
Just because your life breaks down does not mean that you have to miss your desire to live.
I'm okana, this is not a cry to help
Promotional content for 'Square Myspace'